Have you ever been conned? Or maybe you know someone who's fallen for a scam? Do you wonder why intelligent people join cults or give money to psychics or get sucked into Ponzi schemes? Have you ever gone to Las Vegas or Atlantic City and wondered what it might feel like to play poker for high stakes? Are the big winners lucky, skillful, or both? Do you feel like your brain is too cluttered with unnecessary facts? Would you like to know how to better organize your mind? Are you wondering what on earth these questions have to do with each other?
你曾经被骗过吗？或者你认识的人里有谁上过当吗？你是否好奇为什么聪明人会加入邪教、给算命先生送钱，或者陷入庞氏骗局？你有没有去过拉斯维加斯或大西洋城，想过在高额赌注下玩扑克是什么感觉？那些大赢家是靠运气、靠技术，还是两者兼有？你是否觉得自己的大脑被太多无用的事实塞满了？你想知道如何更好地整理自己的思维吗？你是否在纳闷这些问题之间到底有什么联系？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. At APA, we often say that psychology is relevant to every aspect of life and that studying psychology can better equip you whatever path you choose. Our guest today is a living, walking, and writing example of that. Maria Konnikova has a PhD in psychology from Columbia University, but she works primarily as a journalist, except for the many months she spent studying and playing Texas Holden, eventually becoming an international poker champion and winning over $300,000 in tournament earnings.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。在美国心理学会，我们常说心理学与生活的方方面面息息相关，无论你选择什么道路，学习心理学都能让你更好地装备自己。我们今天的嘉宾就是这方面的活生生、会走路、会写作的典范。玛丽亚·康尼科娃（Maria Konnikova）拥有哥伦比亚大学心理学博士学位，但她主要以记者的身份工作，除了她花了好几个月时间学习和玩德州扑克，最终成为国际扑克冠军并赢得了超过30万美元的锦标赛奖金之外。
She's also studied con artists from fortune tellers to the purveyors of the Nigerian print scam to three-card Monty players on the streets of New York, and she has applied her knowledge of psychology to understanding and explaining how to think like Sherlock Holmes and how not to think like Dr. Watson. Konnikova has written three best-selling books, Mastermind How to Think Like Sherlock Holmes, the Confidence Game, and her latest, the biggest bluff. Her writing has been featured in Best American Science and Nature writing and has been translated into more than 20 languages. She's also a contributing writer for the New Yorker magazine and host of the podcast series The Grift, which explores, con artists and the lives they wreck. Maria Konnikova, welcome to speaking of psychology. Thank you so much for having me.
她还研究过各种骗子，从算命先生到尼日利亚骗局的始作俑者，再到纽约街头的“三张牌”赌徒。她运用自己的心理学知识来理解和解释如何像夏洛克·福尔摩斯那样思考，以及如何避免像华生医生那样思考。康尼科娃撰写了三本畅销书：《大师思维：像福尔摩斯一样思考》（Mastermind: How to Think Like Sherlock Holmes）、《欺骗游戏》（The Confidence Game），以及她最新的作品《最大的虚张声势》（The Biggest Bluff）。她的作品曾入选《美国最佳科学与自然写作》，并被翻译成20多种语言。她还是《纽约客》杂志的特约撰稿人，也是播客系列《骗局》（The Grift）的主持人，该系列探讨了骗子及其摧毁的人生。玛丽亚·康尼科娃，欢迎来到《心理学谈话》。非常感谢邀请我。
It's a pleasure. Just reading your biography could make anyone feel like a goldbricker, which is actually a type of work-of-wording grifter that you describe in the confidence game. And I didn't even mention that you did your graduate work at Harvard, where you studied psychology, creative writing, and government. Were you just trying to make up your mind what to be when you grew up? No, I think I always knew I wanted to be a writer. According to, well, I don't know if it's apocryphal, but I don't remember it because I was five years old or so.
这是我的荣幸。光是读你的简历就足以让人觉得自己像个“金砖骗子”（goldbricker），这实际上是你《欺骗游戏》中描述的一种骗子。我甚至还没提到你在哈佛大学完成了研究生学业，在那里你学习了心理学、创意写作和政府学。你当时是在纠结长大后要做什么吗？不，我想我一直都知道自己想成为一名作家。根据——好吧，我不知道这是否是杜撰的，因为我不记得了，因为那时我大概五岁左右。
But according to my family, I informed everyone over dinner when I was about five that I was going to be a writer when I grew up. And that's all I've ever wanted to do. But I just love learning and I love the human mind. And so I didn't know that I loved psychology until high school. And we had this amazing psychology teacher, Pamela Lynn. So if she happens to listen to this, she's wonderful. And she taught advanced placement psychology. And she assigned Oliver Sacks, the man who mistook his wife for a hat as summer reading.
但据我的家人说，我五岁左右在晚餐时告诉大家，我长大后要成为一名作家。这就是我一直想做的事情。但我只是热爱学习，热爱人类的心智。所以我直到高中才知道自己热爱心理学。我们有一位非常棒的心理学老师，帕梅拉·林恩（Pamela Lynn）。如果她碰巧在听这个节目，她真的很棒。她教的是大学先修课程心理学。她布置的暑期阅读书目是奥利弗·萨克斯（Oliver Sacks）的《错把妻子当帽子的人》（The Man Who Mistook His Wife for a Hat）。
And I remember reading that and just saying, oh, my God, my mind has been blown. You can do this. You can write about this. This is ridiculously cool. And we also read Stephen Pinker's The Language Instinct. You know, she assigned, I think, some of the greats who both practiced and were brilliant writers. So when I, by the time I got to college, I thought, oh, I'm going to register. So as you mentioned, I did my undergrad at Harvard.
我记得读完那本书后，我惊叹道：“天哪，我的大脑被震撼了。”你可以做这个。你可以写关于这个的内容。这简直太酷了。我们还读了斯蒂芬·平克（Stephen Pinker）的《语言本能》（The Language Instinct）。你知道，她布置的阅读书目里，我想，都是一些既是实践者又是杰出作家的伟人。所以，当我上大学时，我想，哦，我要注册。正如你提到的，我在哈佛读了本科。
And I thought, oh, I'm going to register at MIT so that I could take a class with Stephen Pinker. But luckily for me, he came to Harvard. so I didn't have to do a cross-registration at MIT, and he ended up actually becoming my undergrad advisor for my thesis, which was in government and psychology, but I also did creative writing, and I did fiction because I had thought that I was going to be a novelist when I grew up, which did not end up happening, but I still love fiction,
我当时想，我要去麻省理工学院（MIT）注册，这样我就能上斯蒂芬·平克的课。但幸运的是，他来到了哈佛，所以我不需要去麻省理工学院跨校注册。他最终成为了我本科论文的导师，我的论文方向是政府学和心理学，但我还选修了创意写作，写的是小说，因为我曾以为自己长大后会成为一名小说家，虽然最终没能实现，但我仍然热爱小说，
and I love reading fiction, and I hope one day, you know, I have probably like a lot of writers, I have, you know, the novel in the drawer, and I hope to one day have the time to explore that side more freely. But this was a very long way to say, I always wanted to be a writer, but I love people and how minds work and how they think. That's what excites me about writing. It's what excites me about psychology. It's why I wanted to be a fiction writer, because as I've said before in other interviews,
我热爱阅读小说，我希望有一天，你知道，可能像许多作家一样，我有一个“抽屉里的小说”，我希望有一天能有时间更自由地探索那一面。但这只是为了说明，我一直想成为一名作家，但我热爱人类，热爱心智如何运作以及人们如何思考。这就是写作让我兴奋的地方。这也是心理学让我兴奋的地方。这就是我为什么想成为一名小说家，因为正如我在其他采访中所说的那样，
I think that the best psychologists are the great novelists and the great poets because they, have had to have such great insight into the human condition to write the way they do and to observe the way they do, that oftentimes they reach certain insights that experimental psychology ends up proving, you know, 100 years later. So in your most recent book, the biggest bluff, you detail how you became a professional poker player. What made you decide to learn to play Texas Haldem? I understand you didn't even have a deck of cards in your house when you were a kid. So why that game and not say another form of poker or even chess? That is all because of the great John von Neumann, who was one of the great polymaths of the 20th century, the father of game theory, the father of the computer, one of the fathers of the hydrogen bomb, just an all-around genius.
我认为最好的心理学家是伟大的小说家和伟大的诗人，因为他们必须对人类状况有如此深刻的洞察力，才能写出那样的作品，才能进行那样的观察。以至于他们往往能得出某些洞察，而实验心理学最终在100年后才证明了这些洞察。那么，在你最近的书《最大的虚张声势》中，你详细描述了自己是如何成为一名职业扑克选手的。是什么让你决定学习玩德州扑克？我听说你小时候家里甚至连一副扑克牌都没有。所以为什么是那个游戏，而不是其他形式的扑克，甚至是国际象棋？这完全是因为伟大的约翰·冯·诺依曼（John von Neumann），他是20世纪伟大的博学家之一，博弈论之父，计算机之父，氢弹之父之一，简直是一位全能的天才。
And in his kind of the foundational text of game theory, the theory of games and economic behavior, which he co-wrote, he writes about games and talks about the fact that he was looking for a way to model complex strategic decision-making, human decision-making at the highest levels. Now, at this time, he was also advising the Security Council of the United States. He was talking about all of the big security issues of the day. So this was not merely academic. And it turns out that game theory is based on poker and that he dismissed chess as actually being completely boring and irrelevant for human decision making because it's a game of perfect information. It's a game where you see everything, right?
在他那本博弈论的奠基性著作《博弈论与经济行为》（Theory of Games and Economic Behavior）中，他与人合著了这本书，他写到了游戏，并谈到了他正在寻找一种方法来模拟复杂的战略决策，即最高水平的人类决策。当时，他还在为美国国家安全委员会提供咨询。他谈论的是当时所有重大的安全问题。所以这不仅仅是学术性的。事实证明，博弈论是以扑克为基础的，他认为国际象棋对于人类决策来说是完全无聊且无关紧要的，因为它是一个“完美信息”游戏。这是一个你能看到一切的游戏，对吧？
You see the entire board. You see all the pieces. And theoretically with enough computing power, you can solve it. there's always a right move. Whereas if you look at a game like poker, that's much more true to life because it's a game of incomplete information. It's a game of uncertainty. It's a game of unknowns. It's a game of people. As he wrote, and this is a quote from him, real life consists of bluffing, of trying to figure out what does this man think I mean to do. And that is what games are about in my theory. And if you think about it, that's just this beautiful insight into psychology and into the fact that here's this mathematician who's saying math is not enough.
你能看到整个棋盘。你能看到所有的棋子。理论上，只要有足够的计算能力，你就能解开它。总有一个正确的走法。而如果你看像扑克这样的游戏，它更贴近生活，因为它是一个“不完全信息”游戏。这是一个充满不确定性的游戏。这是一个充满未知数的游戏。这是一个关于人的游戏。正如他所写的——这是引用他的话——“现实生活包括虚张声势，试图弄清楚这个人认为我打算做什么。这就是我的理论中游戏的核心。”如果你仔细想想，这对于心理学来说是一个非常美丽的洞察，而且这位数学家说数学是不够的。
You know, computation is not enough. Chess is not life because life is like poker. Life is a game of unknowns of incomplete information where you have to make all of these deductions and you have to constantly change and adjust based on the people you're playing with. And so math is not enough. You need psychology. And that's where game theory kind of came in. He wanted to solve poker. And he thought that if he could solve it, he would have the answer the key to strategic decision making that he'd be able to prevent nuclear war. Really, that's not me exaggerating. And no limit holdum is the variation of poker that in terms of the balance of known to unknown information, best mirrors decision-making in life. Because in some other variations, there's too much unknown, right? There are too many down cards and too much private information, and it becomes too much gambling, right? It becomes too much like roulette. There's not quite enough to go on. And in other variants of poker, there's too much information in common, and it becomes too kind of easy to solve because there's only one whole card and everything else is visible and all the other information is in common. And so no limit holdum is kind of this beautiful balance of knowns to
你知道，计算是不够的。国际象棋不是生活，因为生活就像扑克。生活是一个充满未知数、充满不完全信息的游戏，你必须做出所有这些推论，并且必须根据你正在与之博弈的人不断改变和调整。所以数学是不够的。你需要心理学。这就是博弈论的切入点。他想解开扑克。他认为如果他能解开它，他就能找到战略决策的关键，从而能够防止核战争。真的，我没有夸张。而无限注德州扑克（No-limit Hold'em）是扑克的一种变体，在已知信息与未知信息的平衡方面，最能反映生活中的决策。因为在其他一些变体中，未知信息太多了，对吧？有太多的底牌和太多的私人信息，它变得太像赌博了，对吧？它变得太像轮盘赌了。没有足够的信息可供参考。而在其他扑克变体中，公共信息太多了，它变得太容易解开了，因为只有一张底牌，其他一切都是可见的，所有其他信息都是公共的。所以无限注德州扑克是一种已知与
unknown. And obviously limit holden is exactly the same in the sense of knowns to unknown. But if you're talking about the game of life, it's a game of no limit. It's a game where you can always wager anything at any given point in time. So it's a much better analog. So I, when I read about this, as you said, I didn't even have a deck of cards. I didn't know. how many cards were in a deck. I had zero interest in any of this, but it intrigued me. And so I started reading about poker, and I just thought, this is, you know, this is it. Why don't I learn to play this game and use it as a way of exploring the balance of skill versus chance in life and to kind of learn to see what kind of a decision maker I can become in this new world that I know
未知的完美平衡。显然，有限注德州扑克在已知与未知的意义上是完全一样的。但如果你谈论的是生活这场游戏，它是一场无限注的游戏。这是一个你可以在任何给定时间点下注任何东西的游戏。所以它是一个更好的模拟。所以，当我读到这些时，正如你所说，我甚至连一副牌都没有。我不知道一副牌里有多少张牌。我对这一切毫无兴趣，但它引起了我的好奇。于是我开始阅读关于扑克的内容，我只是想，这就是了。为什么我不学习玩这个游戏，并把它作为一种探索生活中技能与运气平衡的方式，并学习看看在这个我一无所知的全新世界里，我能成为什么样的决策者呢？
nothing about. So in the book, you describe how you would apply psychological theories and research to your play, and yet sometimes you acted in ways that contravened what you know as a psychologist. Could you talk about some of the ways in which psychology informed your study and playing of poker and then maybe sometimes when you didn't follow the science and how that turned out? I think that poker is kind of a kick in the pants for any psychologist who, thinks they know it all. So I, you know, I, when I was studying psychology, I didn't just study any, like, some random topic. My dissertation was on risky decision-making under conditions of uncertainty. And I looked at self-control and hot emotional conditions. My advisor was the late
在书中，你描述了你是如何将心理学理论和研究应用到你的博弈中的，然而有时你的行为却违背了你作为心理学家的认知。你能谈谈心理学在哪些方面影响了你的扑克学习和博弈，以及有时你没有遵循科学的情况，结果如何吗？我认为对于任何认为自己无所不知的心理学家来说，扑克就像是一记当头棒喝。所以，你知道，当我学习心理学时，我研究的不仅仅是某个随机课题。我的博士论文是关于不确定条件下的风险决策。我研究了自我控制和热情绪状态。我的导师是已故的
great Walter Michelle. I was his final graduate student. And so we were looking at, you know, self-control in the trading environment and the stock market and how, you know, different people would make different decisions with a lot of pressure on them. And so if you think about poker, you know, I didn't just have random theoretical knowledge. I had knowledge that directly talked about risky decision-making and emotional decision-making. And so I thought that I would actually be able to use that pretty well. But it turns out that there's a big, big gulf between theory and practice. And knowing, you know, as Danny Kahneman has said many times,
伟大的沃尔特·米歇尔（Walter Mischel）。我是他最后一名研究生。所以我们研究的是交易环境和股票市场中的自我控制，以及不同的人在压力下会做出不同的决策。所以如果你想到扑克，你知道，我不仅仅拥有随机的理论知识。我拥有的知识直接涉及风险决策和情绪决策。所以我认为我实际上能够很好地利用这些知识。但事实证明，理论与实践之间存在巨大的鸿沟。而且正如丹尼·卡尼曼（Danny Kahneman）多次说过的那样，
knowing about a bias doesn't mean he doesn't exhibit that's exact bias. And that's what I found in my personal experience that, you know, I'd spent years studying self-control and, you know, I'd worked with the Bing sample, which is that, you know, the famous sample of marshmallow kids from the Stanford Bing Elementary School. You know, I actually was able to kind of work with some of those original students and learn a lot about self-control and making hot decisions. And so I thought that when you put me at a poker table with all this pressure and all this emotional stuff going on, that I'd have all
了解一种偏见并不意味着他不会表现出那种偏见。这就是我在个人经历中发现的，你知道，我花了好几年时间研究自我控制，你知道，我曾与“宾氏样本”（Bing sample）合作过，也就是斯坦福宾氏小学著名的棉花糖实验儿童样本。你知道，我实际上能够与其中一些最初的学生一起工作，并学到了很多关于自我控制和做出“热”决策的知识。所以我以为，当你把我放在一个充满压力和情绪波动的扑克桌上时，我会拥有所有的
the strategies at my fingertips. And the funny thing was, I did. And I could watch myself making these errors and saying, wait, I should be doing this. I should be doing that. Wait, I'm, you know, I'm not distant enough. I'm actually being irrational. I'm being too emotional. I'm letting this affect me this way, oh, this is the gambler's fallacy, oh, this is, you know, the hot hand fallacy. I could just see it happening. And I couldn't stop myself. And sometimes I even knew what the tools were and what techniques I should use. And I couldn't implement them. And it was just, it was very interesting from, you know, from a psychological standpoint, because it was like two different mes, right? Maria watching Maria. And one Maria saying, what in the world are you
策略，信手拈来。有趣的是，我确实拥有。我能看着自己犯下这些错误，并说：“等等，我应该这样做。我应该那样做。等等，我，你知道，我不够冷静。我实际上表现得很不理性。我太情绪化了。我让这种情况以这种方式影响我，哦，这是赌徒谬误，哦，这是，你知道，热手谬误。”我能清楚地看到它正在发生。但我无法阻止自己。有时我甚至知道工具是什么，以及我应该使用什么技术。但我无法实施它们。从心理学的角度来看，这非常有趣，因为这就像两个不同的我，对吧？玛丽亚看着玛丽亚。一个玛丽亚说：“你到底在
doing? And the other Maria saying, I don't know. but I can't stop because it turns out that a lot of this research is so true because it's real. And when you actually put yourself in that environment, you see how these biases can occur. And when it's you and you're emotionally involved and you haven't trained or prepared for this moment, it's really difficult in the moment to kind of tell your higher executive function. to turn on and to actually act properly. So I ended up having to work with a mental game coach who helped train me to use what I knew as a psychologist and actually apply it to myself in the moment.
做什么？”而另一个玛丽亚说：“我不知道。但我无法停止。”因为事实证明，很多研究之所以如此真实，是因为它们就是现实。当你真正把自己置身于那种环境中时，你就会看到这些偏见是如何发生的。当你身处其中，情绪受到牵连，且没有为这一刻进行过训练或准备时，在当下让你的高级执行功能开启并真正采取正确的行动是非常困难的。所以我最终不得不与一位心理博弈教练合作，他帮助训练我利用我作为心理学家的知识，并真正将其应用到当下的自己身上。
And that involved a lot of practice and a lot of time away from the table basically practicing what I would do in these different situations. And that also required a lot of self-reflection to try to figure out, okay, okay, when am I not being rational? When do I stop thinking like a psychologist and start thinking just like a scared person who doesn't know what she's doing? I found that interesting, you'd already studied con artists. You'd written the confidence game, and yet there were still instances where people at the poker table could sort of get you, like speaking Russian or, you know, looking like just a little old man who didn't know what he was doing. and those kinds of scenarios where you would, you'd slip like average people, not like a, you know, psychologist.
这涉及大量的练习和大量离开牌桌的时间，基本上是在练习我在这些不同情况下会怎么做。这也需要大量的自我反思，试图弄清楚：“好吧，好吧，我什么时候表现得不理性了？我什么时候停止像心理学家那样思考，开始像一个不知道自己在做什么的受惊的人那样思考了？”我觉得这很有趣，你已经研究过骗子了。你写过《欺骗游戏》，然而在扑克桌上仍然有实例，人们可以以某种方式欺骗你，比如用俄语说话，或者，你知道，看起来就像一个不知道自己在做什么的小老头。在那些场景中，你会像普通人一样失误，而不是像一个心理学家。
Yeah, it's true. It's true. Because, I mean, one of the things I learned from the confidence game is just the power of belief and how susceptible we are when we're not on alert, when we're not constantly, you know, thinking, oh, this person's out to get me. And we're not because that's not the way the world works. And can you imagine going through life every single person you meet saying this person is out to get me, right? What are they hiding? What are they trying to sell me? It's a very miserable, difficult, and lonely way to go through life. And I think our default is very different. There's a lot of work on trust that shows that we actually kind of trust is our default state, that in the absence of any evidence, we trust each other.
是的，这是真的。这是真的。因为，我的意思是，我从《欺骗游戏》中学到的一件事就是信念的力量，以及当我们没有保持警惕时，当我们没有时刻在想“哦，这个人想害我”时，我们是多么容易受到影响。我们不会那样想，因为世界不是那样运作的。你能想象在生活中遇到的每一个人都说“这个人想害我”吗？他们隐藏着什么？他们想卖给我什么？这是一种非常悲惨、困难且孤独的生活方式。我认为我们的默认状态是非常不同的。有很多关于信任的研究表明，我们实际上倾向于将信任作为默认状态，即在没有任何证据的情况下，我们信任彼此。
And normally it goes over quite well. And normally we're successful that way because most people aren't psychopaths. And most people are not going to take advantage of that trust. I mean, the reason psychopaths thrive is because they're at such a lovely minority of the population that it's adaptive for them. But if there were more of them, that would no longer be the case. We'd recognize them. Exactly. Exactly.
通常情况下，这效果很好。通常我们通过这种方式获得成功，因为大多数人不是精神病态者。大多数人不会利用这种信任。我的意思是，精神病态者之所以能茁壮成长，是因为他们只占人口中极小的一部分，这对他们来说是适应性的。但如果他们更多的话，情况就不会这样了。我们会认出他们。完全正确。完全正确。
And so I think that the confidence game showed me how little I could do to prepare myself in the sense that if someone is determined to deceive you and knows you and is good at it and can kind of push your right buttons, it's really, it can be very difficult to see through that. And it can be very difficult to avoid being conned when the con is something that. that meshes with your worldview, meshes with how you already think things should be with what you're predisposed to believe. And so when I found myself in some of these situations that you refer to at the poker table, I think I just, you know, my guard was down because while poker is a game of deception, you know, the deceptions is part of the rules. You're supposed to bluff people. you're kind of supposed to do that. And yet I let that creep into how I thought people would play against me given how they spoke to me. And so there were people who tried to manipulate me by,
所以我认为《欺骗游戏》向我展示了我在准备方面能做的有多么有限，因为如果有人决心欺骗你，并且了解你，而且擅长此道，并且能触动你的正确开关，那么看穿这一点真的非常困难。当骗局与你的世界观相吻合，与你已经认为事情应该有的样子相吻合，与你倾向于相信的东西相吻合时，想要避免被骗是非常困难的。所以当我在扑克桌上发现自己处于你提到的某些情况时，我想我只是，你知道，我放松了警惕，因为虽然扑克是一个欺骗游戏，你知道，欺骗是规则的一部分。你应该虚张声势地欺骗别人。你某种程度上应该那样做。然而，我让这种想法渗透到了我对他人的看法中，考虑到他们对我说话的方式。所以有些人试图通过以下方式操纵我：
you know, being very nice and friendly and having an open conversation with me and kind of showing that it was us against the world, kind of, and then bluffing me relentlessly. And you know what? Good for them because that's within the rules. They weren't even conning me. That was, that's, that's, that's part of the game. I was just a victim. I was, I was a sap. I was the person who fell for it, even though I should have known better. And that did teach me. I think I'm a lot better at that now, um, at realizing that, you know, there's no such thing as friends at the poker table is the way the saying goes. Um, and I don't think that's quite right. I think there are friends, but when you're playing against each other in that hand, you should forget whether your friends or not and just play
你知道，表现得非常友善和友好，与我进行开放式的交谈，并表现出这是一种“我们对抗世界”的感觉，然后无情地虚张声势地欺骗我。你知道吗？这对他们来说很好，因为这在规则之内。他们甚至没有在骗我。那是，那是，那是游戏的一部分。我只是一个受害者。我是一个傻瓜。我是那个上当受骗的人，尽管我本应该更清楚。这确实教会了我。我想我现在在这方面好多了，意识到，你知道，正如俗话所说，扑克桌上没有朋友。嗯，我不认为这完全正确。我认为有朋友，但当你在那手牌中互相对抗时，你应该忘记你们是否是朋友，只需玩
and play the rationally optimal game. Is there a big difference then between the bluff and the con? Oh, absolutely. It's a totally different thing. It's all a matter of intention. So con artists take advantage of people for their own personal gain and they deceive you knowingly. And it's kind of it's something that's nefarious in the intent. And poker, like I said, bluffing is part of the game. It's in the rules. Everyone knows it. It's not like someone is trying to break a rule by cheating, right? And if you're, if you're bluffing, you're actually just playing the game. And so everyone knows. Everyone is playing by the same rules. And it's it's very, very different because the intention is to play a game, not to, take advantage of someone for your own personal ends. And if you end up cheating in poker,
并玩出理性上最优的游戏。那么虚张声势（bluff）和欺诈（con）之间有很大的区别吗？哦，绝对有。这是完全不同的两回事。这完全取决于意图。所以骗子为了自己的个人利益利用他人，他们明知故犯地欺骗你。这是一种意图邪恶的行为。而在扑克中，就像我说的，虚张声势是游戏的一部分。它在规则之内。每个人都知道。这不像有人试图通过作弊来破坏规则，对吧？如果你在虚张声势，你实际上只是在玩游戏。所以每个人都知道。每个人都在遵守同样的规则。这非常、非常不同，因为意图是玩游戏，而不是为了你自己的个人目的利用他人。如果你最终在扑克中作弊，
of course there are con artists in poker who break the rules, right? People who try to mark cards or who have other ways of signaling each other, you know, have spotters on the rail who try to look at your cards and signal to them what they should be doing. Well, that's, you know, those, that's cheating, right? That's a different game now. And they're a con artist in every single profession. I mean, hell, they're con artists within the psychology profession. We've caught some of them. And their papers have luckily, you know, been all withdrawn. But I'm sure that there are some of them who falsified data who are still out there. Did your study of con artists make you more attuned to the people who might be cheating or just the card sharps who were out there?
当然，扑克中也有破坏规则的骗子，对吧？试图标记扑克牌的人，或者有其他方式互相打信号的人，你知道，在场边有观察员试图看你的牌并向他们发出信号，告诉他们应该做什么。嗯，那是，你知道，那些，那是作弊，对吧？那现在是另一场游戏了。每个行业都有骗子。我的意思是，见鬼，心理学行业内部也有骗子。我们已经抓到了一些。幸运的是，他们的论文都被撤回了。但我敢肯定，还有一些伪造数据的人仍然逍遥法外。你对骗子的研究是否让你对那些可能在作弊的人，或者那些在场外的老千更加敏感了？
Well, I think that I saw some of the more blatant examples of this. But what you learn from con artists is the danger of thinking that you know how to spot one, because the best con artists are ones that you'll never see coming. And it's incredibly difficult to know when someone is deceiving you if they're good at it. That's why lie detector tests are so notoriously unreliable because they can capture cognitive load, but they have no idea what that cognitive load is actually signaling, right? Is it deception? Is it discomfort?
嗯，我想我看到了一些更明显的例子。但你从骗子身上学到的是，认为自己知道如何识别骗子是多么危险，因为最好的骗子是你永远无法预料到的。如果一个人擅长欺骗，想要知道他何时在欺骗你简直难如登天。这就是为什么测谎仪如此臭名昭著地不可靠，因为它们可以捕捉认知负荷，但它们根本不知道这种认知负荷实际上在暗示什么，对吧？是欺骗吗？是不适吗？
Is it stress because of something totally unrelated? You don't really know. And in poker, I think that's the same thing. And the better someone is, the fewer signals there are, the less likely you are to pick up on anything. You know, when I was researching the confidence game, I actually, about halfway through the research process, stopped spending time with the con artists I was writing about. And the reason I did that was because I had a really scary moment when I was with this lovely old man and he was a card shark. And I, you know, I knew he was a con artist. You know, he'd actually, he was one of the few who'd actually been in jail.
是因为完全无关的事情而产生的压力吗？你真的不知道。在扑克中，我认为也是一样。一个人越厉害，信号就越少，你察觉到任何事情的可能性就越小。你知道，当我在研究《欺骗游戏》时，我实际上在研究过程进行到一半时，停止了与我所写的那些骗子共处。我之所以这样做，是因为我经历了一个非常可怕的时刻，当时我和这个可爱的老头在一起，他是一个老千。我，你知道，我知道他是个骗子。你知道，他实际上是少数几个真正坐过牢的人之一。
He was caught up. He was involved with the mob and he was caught up on racketeering charges. And he was now in his late 70s, I guess, when he was caught up. when he and I spoke, I was just sitting and thoroughly enjoying our conversation and I was thinking, oh, you know, he's not so bad. And he was like, oh, you know, like he had him coming. I'm like, yeah, he did have it coming. Yeah. You know, this isn't so bad. And he's like, you know, you should come out to my house in Connecticut. I'll teach you. I was like, yeah, absolutely. I want you to be my grandfather. You know, this is great. And then I just, like, part of me after the fact was
他被卷入了黑帮，并因敲诈勒索罪被捕。他现在已经70多岁了，我想，当他被抓的时候。当我们交谈时，我只是坐着，非常享受我们的谈话，我想：“哦，你知道，他没那么坏。”他就像是：“哦，你知道，就像他罪有应得。”我说：“是的，他确实罪有应得。是的。”你知道，“这没那么坏。”他说：“你知道，你应该来我在康涅狄格州的家。我会教你的。”我说：“是的，绝对。我希望你做我的祖父。你知道，这太棒了。”然后我只是，就像事后我的一部分
horrified. And I thought, what in the world? And he was so charismatic that he'd gotten me totally caught up in it. And I didn't realize it was happening. And I saw that these con artists, a lot of them had such great charisma that I was starting to buy their side of the story. And so it wasn't actually helping me be a better journalist. It wasn't objective reporting because they were so good at making the narrative fit their needs, and they were so good at using their charisma, using their influence, using kind of their appeal to make you see the world from their perspective that you stopped being objective. And that scared me because I wanted to represent the victims. I wanted to show that these were bad people because don't, you know,
感到震惊。我想：“这到底是怎么回事？”他太有魅力了，以至于我完全被他吸引住了。我没有意识到这正在发生。我看到这些骗子，他们中的许多人都有如此大的魅力，以至于我开始相信他们的那一面故事。所以这实际上并没有帮助我成为一名更好的记者。这不是客观报道，因为他们太擅长让叙事符合他们的需求，而且他们太擅长利用他们的魅力、利用他们的影响力、利用他们的吸引力让你从他们的角度看世界，以至于你不再客观了。这让我感到害怕，因为我想代表受害者。我想表明这些人是坏人，因为，你知道，
make no two ways about it. Every single person I write about in the confidence game, all of the con artists are horrible individuals who've ruined lives, right? This nice grandfather card shark, he took advantage by cheating of honest people who wanted to have fun and, you know, went to a casino and this guy ran a crooked game and just took all of their money and made them go broke. These aren't people who deserve it. These are people who have lost a lot because people have been unscrupulous. And that's... That was, you know, one of the fringe examples. Other examples are much more egregious.
毫无疑问。我在《欺骗游戏》中写的每一个人，所有的骗子都是毁掉他人生活的可怕个体，对吧？这个可爱的祖父老千，他通过欺骗那些想找乐子、去了赌场的老实人来占便宜，而这家伙经营着一场黑局，拿走了他们所有的钱，让他们破产。这些人不是罪有应得的人。这些人因为不择手段的人而损失惨重。那是……那是，你知道，边缘例子之一。其他例子要严重得多。
Are there characteristics of the people who can be conned that you saw across the many people you studied? I mean, there are a lot of folks who were otherwise incredibly smart who gave millions of dollars to Bernie Madoff, for example. Oh, for sure. I mean, I think that every single person can be conned. I actually don't think that there's an exception. Literally, I mean, I'm willing to make a blanket statement like that. I don't think everyone can fall for every con artist or for every con, but I do think there's a con out there for everyone. Because everyone believes in something and everyone hopes in something.
在你研究的许多人中，有没有被骗者的一些共同特征？我的意思是，有很多非常聪明的人，例如，把数百万美元给了伯尼·麦道夫（Bernie Madoff）。哦，当然。我的意思是，我认为每个人都可能被骗。我实际上不认为有例外。字面上说，我的意思是，我愿意做出这样的笼统陈述。我不认为每个人都会上每一个骗子的当，或者陷入每一个骗局，但我确实认为每个人都有一个适合他们的骗局。因为每个人都相信某些东西，每个人都对某些东西抱有希望。
And everyone sees the world subjectively. Even if you're the greatest skeptic of all time, you know, there are still, you've got your own pet theories about the world. And someone can use that, someone who's very, very good. Unless you, maybe if you lock yourself up in a room, throw, way the key and never interact with anyone or meet anyone, maybe you won't be con. But otherwise, I think everyone is susceptible. And when you start looking at kind of characteristics, originally I thought, oh, maybe we'll find that, you know, people are, have a lower IQ or are less educated or this or that. And none of that's true. None. There's actually, when you're
每个人都主观地看待世界。即使你是史上最伟大的怀疑论者，你知道，你仍然有你自己关于世界的“宠物理论”。而有人可以利用这一点，一个非常、非常厉害的人。除非你，也许如果你把自己锁在一个房间里，扔掉钥匙，从不与任何人互动或见面，也许你不会被骗。但除此之外，我认为每个人都容易受到影响。当你开始观察那种特征时，最初我想：“哦，也许我们会发现，你知道，人们的智商较低，或者受教育程度较低，或者这样那样。”这些都不是真的。一点也不。实际上，当你
starting to talk about individual differences like that, there's nothing that's predictive at all. But there are a few things that actually make you more susceptible. And the one that I would say is the biggest factor is not anything about personality or who you are, but where you are in life. So people who are in moments of transition in their life become more susceptible to being conned. So it can be oftentimes it's negative transitions, right? It's like a major life change. You know, someone died or you're going through a divorce or you've lost. your job or we're going through a pandemic, right? Something terrible has happened. Those,
开始谈论像那样的个体差异时，根本没有任何预测性。但确实有几件事让你更容易受到影响。我要说最大的因素不是关于个性或你是谁，而是你处于人生的哪个阶段。所以那些处于人生转型期的人更容易被骗。所以这通常是负面的转型，对吧？就像重大的生活变故。你知道，有人去世了，或者你正在经历离婚，或者你失去了工作，或者我们正在经历一场大流行，对吧？发生了可怕的事情。那些
those negative life changes can be huge, but they can be also positive. You know, maybe you got a new job and you've just moved to a new city and you still, your sense of stability is gone because everything is new and everything is unknown. Maybe you just had a baby. And once again, your world has completely changed. So when you're in a moment of life change, whether it's positive or negative, even though more often than not it's negative, you become susceptible to con-artists because you crave stability and meaning and something that makes sense. And they're very good at giving that. They're very good at sense-making. They're very good at providing you with something to lean on with kind of a good story, with a good support at a time when you need it most. Because they can sense
负面的生活变化可能是巨大的，但它们也可能是积极的。你知道，也许你得到了一份新工作，刚搬到一个新城市，你仍然，你的稳定感消失了，因为一切都是新的，一切都是未知的。也许你刚生了一个孩子。再一次，你的世界完全改变了。所以当你处于生活变化的时刻，无论是积极的还是消极的，尽管更多时候是消极的，你就会变得容易受到骗子的影响，因为你渴望稳定、意义和有意义的东西。他们非常擅长提供这些。他们非常擅长“意义构建”。他们非常擅长在你最需要的时候，用一个好故事、好的支持来为你提供依靠。因为他们能感觉到
that. They can sense that vulnerability and they fill in the blanks that. That, don't actually exist, but they know you want them filled. And so they do that for you. A lot of con artists actually, this is, it's heartbreaking, but it's true, they'll stock, you know, these groups of recent widows or, you know, groups of people who've lost their child to some specific disease. They'll join these support groups. There was one con artist who joined this war widows group, and she became friends. This was a very long con with all of these women over the course of a year, two years, and then she ended up wiping out all of their savings by individually talking to all of them
那种脆弱，他们填补了实际上并不存在的空白，但他们知道你希望填补它们。所以他们为你做了这些。许多骗子实际上——这令人心碎，但这是事实——他们会盯上，你知道，这些最近丧偶的人群，或者，你知道，那些孩子死于某种特定疾病的人群。他们会加入这些支持小组。有一个骗子加入了这个战争遗孀小组，她成为了朋友。这是一个非常漫长的骗局，在一年、两年的时间里，她与所有这些女性建立了友谊，然后她通过分别与她们每个人交谈，
and giving the sob story and they all lent her money because she was a friend. And then she disappeared. Much of your writing has focused on risk assessment, whether that's deciding whether to bet or fold or agreeing to give that special fortune teller another $10,000. So given your study of risk, what have you observed regarding people's risk taking and risk assessment? And how is it playing out during the pandemic? Because we always have to talk about the pandemic.
讲述悲惨故事，最终卷走了她们所有的积蓄，她们都借钱给她，因为她是朋友。然后她消失了。你的许多写作都集中在风险评估上，无论是决定下注还是弃牌，还是同意给那个特别的算命先生再多1万美元。所以鉴于你对风险的研究，你观察到了人们在风险承担和风险评估方面的什么情况？在大流行期间，这种情况是如何表现的？因为我们总是必须谈论大流行。
Well, we suck at it. We're very, very bad for the very simple reasons that human brains and statistics don't get along, never have. And even statisticians tend to be bad at applying statistics to everyday decisions because that's where we started off. podcast, right, theory versus practice. You can know it in theory, but that's very, very different from actually internalizing it and feeling it and knowing, you know, what does 1% feel like? What does 10% feel like? What does 80% feel like? Which, by the way, is why poker is such a great tool. Because one of the reasons we're so horrible at statistics in our everyday lives is that the brain learns from experience and from things that have happened to you, to someone you know,
嗯，我们在这方面很烂。我们非常、非常糟糕，原因很简单：人类大脑和统计学合不来，从来都没有合得来过。即使是统计学家也往往不擅长将统计学应用于日常决策，因为这就是我们开始这个播客的地方，对吧，理论与实践。你可以在理论上知道它，但这与真正内化它、感受它并知道，你知道，1%是什么感觉？10%是什么感觉？80%是什么感觉？顺便说一句，这就是为什么扑克是一个如此伟大的工具。因为我们在日常生活中对统计学如此糟糕的原因之一是，大脑从经验和发生在你身上、发生在你认识的人身上的事情中学习，
and not from description, not from what you read. And our experiences, statistically speaking, are skewed, right? They're not actually representative. We don't live in a representative distribution of events. And so we tend to, you know, overweight things that we might have personally experienced, underweight things that we haven't personally experienced. And so we end up with these skewed notions, especially when it comes to small statistics. You know, what is what is 1%, what is half a person?
而不是从描述中，不是从你读到的东西中学习。而我们的经验，从统计学上讲，是有偏差的，对吧？它们实际上并不具有代表性。我们并不生活在一个事件的代表性分布中。所以我们倾向于，你知道，过度权衡我们可能亲身经历过的事情，低估我们没有亲身经历过的事情。所以我们最终会产生这些扭曲的概念，特别是在涉及小概率统计时。你知道，什么是1%，什么是半个人？
What is 2%. The best example of the fact that even the best thinkers about this sometimes find it very difficult to use in their everyday life happened at the beginning of the pandemic, a few months in. When I interviewed Danny Connaman for the New Yorker Radio Hour, and we talked about kind of since he won a Nobel Prize for his work on risk assessments and how we think about this, I was asking about his own. kind of thoughts on the pandemic and what was happening in. And he told me that in the early days, back in March 2020, he was going to go to Paris for a conference that he had had planned. And this was already, you know, New York was going into lockdown. And he looked at the numbers and he thought, well, you know, these aren't so bad. You know, it's, oh, the absolute numbers aren't so bad. You know, maybe I'm just going to go. And he actually, he didn't cancel the trip. And he started packing and was almost ready to go to the airport. And he is older and he's diabetic. He has a lot of risk factors. And then it just hit him. And he thought, oh my God, you know, exponential growth, right?
什么是2%？关于即使是最好的思想家有时也发现很难在日常生活中应用这一事实的最好例子，发生在大流行开始时，几个月后。当我为《纽约客》广播时间采访丹尼·卡尼曼时，我们谈到了他因为在风险评估和我们如何思考这个问题上的工作而获得了诺贝尔奖，我问了他关于他自己对大流行和正在发生的事情的看法。他告诉我，在早期，回到2020年3月，他打算去巴黎参加一个他已经计划好的会议。这已经是，你知道，纽约正在进入封锁状态。他看了看数字，心想：“嗯，你知道，这些数字没那么糟。你知道，哦，绝对数字没那么糟。你知道，也许我还是去吧。”他实际上，他没有取消行程。他开始打包，几乎准备去机场了。而且他年纪大了，患有糖尿病。他有很多风险因素。然后它突然击中了他。他想：“天哪，你知道，指数增长，对吧？”
The fact that the absolute numbers are so low right now mean nothing. Let me look at what they were yesterday the day before. And it just, he said that he was just deeply personally embarrassed for himself that his risk assessment was just completely off. He thought that it wasn't so bad when really it was terrifying because he won the Nobel for understanding this. But now here he is making his own decision, looking at these numbers, thinking, yeah, you know, let's just go and do this trip. I have already committed to it. And so that just goes to show how difficult it is to make those sorts of decisions in everyday life based on those small numbers. Now, Now, a poker player actually understands statistics correctly because you've played hundreds of thousands
“现在的绝对数字这么低，什么也说明不了。让我看看昨天、前天的情况。”他说，他对自己感到深深的个人尴尬，因为他的风险评估完全错了。他认为情况没那么糟，而实际上这很可怕，因为他因为理解这一点而获得了诺贝尔奖。但现在他在这里做自己的决定，看着这些数字，心想：“是的，你知道，我们去吧，做这次旅行。我已经承诺了。”所以这足以说明在日常生活中基于那些小数字做出那种决定是多么困难。现在，扑克选手实际上能正确理解统计学，因为你玩过几十万
of hands. So you've sampled correctly. So if you know the math, you actually know what 1% feels like. You know what 10% feels like because you've actually sampled it over and over and over and over. And you start realizing. So when people are saying, oh, you know, 1% mortality or something like that, I would say, that's huge. You know, I would kill for a 1% edge at the poker table because that means I'm going to eventually take all your money. You know, one percent is a lot. And people, you know, people will study for
手牌。所以你已经正确地进行了采样。所以如果你懂数学，你实际上知道1%是什么感觉。你知道10%是什么感觉，因为你实际上一次又一次、一次又一次地采样了它。你开始意识到。所以当人们说：“哦，你知道，1%的死亡率或类似的东西，”我会说：“那太大了。”你知道，我愿意为了扑克桌上的1%优势而杀人，因为这意味着我最终会拿走你所有的钱。你知道，1%很多。而人们，你知道，人们会研究……
hours and hours and hours to get an extra half a, you know, half a percentage edge to kind of improve their win rate that much. And you see that when you're 98.6 percent favorite to win a hand, you still will lose. And you will lose more frequently than you think you should because nothing's 100 percent. And so you start to feel it viscerally in your gut. And so that hopes you internalize. and make better decisions, better risk assessments in real life. Once again, going back to the pandemic, when I'm on social media, when I'm on Twitter, I actually have my feeds broken up into different lists. So I have my psychology list. I have my poker player list and, you know, my news list. It turns out that in the early days of the pandemic, the people who saw how serious it was going to be
花费数小时又数小时，只为获得那额外的百分之零点几的优势，从而在很大程度上提高胜率。你会发现，即使你赢牌的概率高达98.6%，你仍然可能会输。而且你输的频率会比你预想的要高，因为没有什么事是百分之百确定的。当你开始从直觉上深刻感受到这一点时，它会帮助你内化这些经验，从而在现实生活中做出更好的决策和风险评估。再次回到疫情期间，当我在社交媒体上，比如在Twitter上时，我实际上把我的信息流分成了不同的列表。我有心理学列表，有扑克玩家列表，还有新闻列表。事实证明，在疫情初期，那些预见到疫情严重性的人
and who actually started taking the most drastic action immediately were the poker players, because they saw the numbers, they understood what they meant and they acted. Not the psychologists. The psychologist were laud-di-da-da. The last event I did before the lockdown was I went to the SPSP convention because they were giving me a media award for journalism. And that was during Mardi Gras when the pandemic was starting. So they did not cancel that conference. Oh, wow.
并且立即开始采取最严厉措施的人，正是那些扑克玩家，因为他们看到了数据，理解了数据的含义，并采取了行动。而不是心理学家。心理学家们当时还是一副漫不经心的样子。我在封锁前参加的最后一个活动是SPSP大会，因为他们要给我颁发一个新闻媒体奖。那是在狂欢节期间，疫情刚刚开始的时候。所以他们没有取消那次会议。哦，天哪。
But no one knew back then, right? Like that was very early days, but at that stage, poker players were already turning around. And I ended up leaving early and canceling. I was supposed to go straight from New Orleans to Los Angeles for a poker tournament. And I ended up canceling the trip to Los Angeles and coming back to New York. And New York went into lockdown two days after I got back. So that brings me around to your book Mastermind and how to think like Sherlock Holmes. because, I mean, a lot of what you write about there has to do with keeping a lot of this information in our brains, in our mental addict, the things that we keep and the things that we discard.
但当时没人知道，对吧？那是非常早期的阶段，但在那个阶段，扑克玩家们已经开始转变了。我最终提前离开并取消了行程。我本打算直接从新奥尔良去洛杉矶参加一场扑克锦标赛。结果我取消了去洛杉矶的行程，回到了纽约。我回到纽约两天后，纽约就进入了封锁状态。这让我想到了你的书《大师思维》（Mastermind）以及如何像夏洛克·福尔摩斯那样思考。因为，你书中写到的很多内容都与如何将这些信息储存在我们的大脑中、我们的心理阁楼里有关，包括我们保留什么以及丢弃什么。
And, you know, you talk about how many of us go through life just looking like Dr. Watson, but not observing like Sherlock Holmes. And it would seem that you used a lot of what you learned writing that book during your stint on the poker circuit. Do you think that you could have become a champion poker player if you hadn't already written mastermind? I have no idea. I try not to deal in counterfactuals. Okay, bad question, Kim. No, I mean, I'm serious. I think it's a counterproductive way of thinking.
而且，你谈到我们中有多少人像华生医生一样生活，却不像夏洛克·福尔摩斯那样去观察。看起来你在扑克圈的那段时间里，运用了很多你在写那本书时学到的东西。你认为如果你没有写过《大师思维》，你还能成为一名扑克冠军吗？我不知道。我尽量不去处理反事实的问题。好吧，这是个糟糕的问题，金。不，我是认真的。我认为这是一种适得其反的思维方式。
So I don't know. And I think that in so many different scenarios, you know, biggest bluff wouldn't have been the biggest bluff. And there are so many, so many, you know, I could have chosen a different. coach. Something could have gone slightly differently. And I could have learned poker just as well with the same coach. And if you think about what actually turned me pro for a few years and what, you know, made this story blow up, it was the fact that I won this major international championship. I could have easily not won. You know, in order to win a title, you have to play with a lot of skill, but you also have to get lucky. And I write about in the book, I tried to be
所以我不知道。而且我认为在许多不同的场景下，你知道，《最大的虚张声势》（The Biggest Bluff）可能就不会是《最大的虚张声势》了。有太多太多的因素，你知道，我本可以选择不同的教练。有些事情可能会有细微的不同。我也可能在同一个教练的指导下同样学好扑克。如果你想想是什么让我真正成为职业选手几年，又是什么让这个故事火起来的，那是因为我赢得了这场重大的国际锦标赛。我完全可能没赢。你知道，要赢得冠军，你必须具备高超的技巧，但也必须有运气。我在书中写过，我尽量做到
very careful because, you know, I was always a researcher and a journalist first and foremost, so I would write down all of my hands during the tournaments, you know, so that I could have a record of what happened. And so in the book, I was very careful to note that there were a few moments in that tournament that I won that I should have, quote unquote, lost and been out of the tournament. and I should have lost all my chips because I got my money in the middle, not as a favorite, but as a dog. You know, I was the one on the bad side of the flip, and I got lucky. And so at the final table, there was one hand that I wrote about where I had pocket sevens, I believe, and someone else had pocket aces. You know, that should be it.
非常谨慎，因为你知道，我首先是一名研究员和记者，所以我会在比赛中记录下我所有的牌局，这样我就能有发生过什么的记录。所以在书中，我非常小心地指出，我在赢得的那场比赛中有几个时刻，我本该，引用我的话，输掉比赛并被淘汰出局。我本该输掉所有的筹码，因为我把钱投入底池时，并不是作为优势方，而是作为劣势方。你知道，我是那个在抛硬币中处于不利地位的人，但我很幸运。所以在决赛桌上，有一手牌我写过，我记得我拿的是口袋7，而别人拿的是口袋A。你知道，那本该结束了。
I should be out of the tournament. I ended up making a straight and, you know, not being knocked out and actually doubling my chips and eventually won. And so all of these moments of luck, you know, they, they conspic. fire to create what ends up being the reality. And so I have no idea, you know, I think that writing mastermind was incredibly beneficial in preparing my mind just to learn well and to learn to take in information and to learn to pay attention. And, you know, when I, when I was researching mastermind, that's when I started meditating. That's when I actually learned a lot about mindfulness. And I still, you know, I do that to this day. And I think that that's been
我本该被淘汰出局。结果我凑成了顺子，没有被淘汰，实际上筹码翻倍，并最终获胜。所以所有这些运气的时刻，它们共同作用，创造了最终的现实。所以我不知道，我认为写《大师思维》在准备我的头脑方面非常有益，让我学会如何学习，学会如何吸收信息，学会如何集中注意力。而且，当我在研究《大师思维》时，我开始冥想。那时我真正学到了很多关于正念的知识。直到今天，我仍然在这样做。我认为这一直
immensely hopeful. And I think that that's one of the habits that, sure, that did enable me to become good at poker. So a lot of different pieces had to come together to make that possible. So you just answered the question I should have asked. It would have been a better question. Thank you. So are you still playing poker? Do you get out there and play? Do you have to play a lot to stay sharp? Or have you kept all the tools handy? Well, so for the first part of the pandemic, I didn't play at all because I am a live player and everything was shut down. And, you know, the last place you want to be is in a casino during a pandemic. And then, you know, after I was vaccinated and pre-Delta and pre-Omacron where things started opening up again, I actually did play and went and played in some events and played in the first World Series that took place since a pandemic. And then kind of stopped playing again with all of the new variants and all of that. And so I think a lot of it has been informed by what was going on epidemiologically and how I felt about that.
非常有帮助。我认为这是让我能够擅长扑克的习惯之一。所以很多不同的因素结合在一起才使这一切成为可能。你刚刚回答了我本该问的问题。那会是一个更好的问题。谢谢。那么你还在打扑克吗？你会出去玩吗？你需要经常玩来保持敏锐吗？还是你已经把所有的工具都放在手边了？嗯，疫情初期我根本没玩，因为我是现场玩家，一切都关闭了。而且，你知道，疫情期间你最不想去的地方就是赌场。后来，在我接种了疫苗，在德尔塔和奥密克戎变异株出现之前，情况开始好转，我确实去玩了一些比赛，还参加了疫情以来举办的第一届世界扑克系列赛。然后随着所有新变异株的出现，我又停止了比赛。所以我认为这很大程度上是基于当时的流行病学情况以及我的感受。
But I see myself as continuing to play, but not at the level that I was playing before. Because when I was pro and was part of Poker Star's Team Pro, I mean, I spent eight months of the year on the road. And that's a lot. And that really took its toll on me. And I'm still and always will be a writer first and foremost. and at this point I also see myself as a poker player and I hope to stay in the game and stay involved in, you know, in advocating for and being an ambassador for it because I think that it's such a great teaching tool. It's such a great way to learn to make better decisions.
但我认为我还会继续玩，但不会达到我以前那种程度。因为当我成为职业选手并加入扑克之星职业队时，我一年中有八个月都在路上。那真的很多。这对我造成了很大的影响。我仍然并将永远首先是一名作家。在这一点上，我也把自己看作一名扑克玩家，我希望留在游戏中，并继续参与其中，为它代言，因为我认为它是一个非常好的教学工具。它是学习做出更好决策的绝佳方式。
And for women, it's just such a great tool of empowerment of learning to tap into kind of your your inner aggression and to, you know, to hold your own. I think it's helped me be better and more successful in other areas of my life, be stronger, be kind of a less socially acceptable, but more successful version of me in a sense. And so I think that's wonderful. And I want more women to find it. And I feel very strongly about that. So I will keep playing. I am still studying and I still try to keep up on it because it does go away if you don't do it and if you don't kind of keep abreast of all of the advances that are happening. But I don't know if I will ever consider myself a professional player again. I doubt it. I think that it will always be semi,
对于女性来说，这是一种非常好的赋权工具，可以学习挖掘你内在的攻击性，并学会坚持自我。我认为这帮助我在生活的其他领域变得更好、更成功，变得更强大，在某种意义上，成为了一个社会接受度较低但更成功的我。所以我认为这很棒。我希望更多的女性能发现这一点。我对此深有感触。所以我还会继续玩。我仍在学习，我仍然努力跟上进度，因为如果你不练习，如果你不跟上所有正在发生的进步，这些技能就会消失。但我不知道我是否还会再把自己视为一名职业选手。我对此表示怀疑。我认为它将永远是半职业的，
you know, either semi-pro or recreational, but it will always be a part of my life. I can really relate to your wanting women to know how to play poker. That was something when I was an undergraduate it a million years ago. A bunch of us got together. I went to Barnard, you know, I'm not part of Columbia. And we formed something we called women's issues poker. And we taught ourselves how to play poker because we knew all men would learn how to play poker and women didn't learn how to play poker. And we would never have the edge if we didn't know these games. Good for you. I'm very happy to hear that. So how do you choose what you want to write about and what are you working on now? I just follow my curiosity to give you the honest answer. I never, I never know
你知道，要么是半职业，要么是娱乐性质，但它将永远是我生活的一部分。我真的能理解你希望女性知道如何打扑克的心情。那是我在读本科时，大概一百万年前的事了。我们一群人聚在一起。我去了巴纳德学院，你知道，我是哥伦比亚大学的一部分。我们成立了一个叫“女性问题扑克”的组织。我们自学如何打扑克，因为我们知道所有的男人都会学打扑克，而女性却不学。如果我们不懂这些游戏，我们就永远不会有优势。为你点赞。听到这个我很高兴。那么你是如何选择你想写的主题的？你现在在忙什么？我只是追随我的好奇心，说实话。我从来不知道
what I'm going to write about next. I just, I read a lot and I try to engage with the world as much as possible and I see kind of what piques my interest and what rabbit hole I go down and which one just won't go away and will kind of keep popping up over and over and over and those tend to be, you know, my next project. Right now I'm thinking about my next book, but I'm not, I don't actually, I'm not quite ready to talk about it. But I'm working on a lot of different things. You know, as I said, I studied fiction as an undergraduate and I'm actually flexing those muscles during the pandemic. I was able to do more exploratory writing. I ended up working on a TV show, so I was in a writer's room for one year of the pandemic.
接下来要写什么。我只是阅读很多，并尽可能多地与世界互动，我看看什么能引起我的兴趣，我钻进哪个兔子洞，哪个兔子洞挥之不去，并不断地反复出现，这些往往就是我下一个项目的主题。现在我正在考虑我的下一本书，但我还没有准备好谈论它。但我正在做很多不同的事情。你知道，正如我所说，我本科学习的是小说创作，在疫情期间我实际上正在锻炼这些肌肉。我能够做更多的探索性写作。我最终参与了一部电视剧的创作，所以在疫情期间我进入了一个编剧室工作了一年。
So that show should be out hopefully next year. And I'm actually doing more screen projects and flexing those narrative muscles. I had an audible original that came out last month called Migraine. That was about my, it was memoristic in the sense that it was about my personal experiences with migraine, but also about the science of it and where we are. in kind of treatment and what's going on with that. And I'm actually working on another audible original about COVID and about the COVID recovery through the lens of Las Vegas, which was the single most affected urban area in the country. The unemployment rate went up to
所以那部剧希望明年能播出。我实际上正在做更多的影视项目，锻炼那些叙事肌肉。我上个月发布了一个Audible原创作品，叫《偏头痛》（Migraine）。那关于我的，它是一种回忆录，讲述了我个人与偏头痛的经历，但也涉及了相关的科学知识，以及我们在治疗方面所处的阶段和进展。我实际上正在制作另一个关于新冠疫情的Audible原创作品，通过拉斯维加斯的视角来审视新冠疫情的恢复，拉斯维加斯是全国受影响最严重的城市地区。失业率上升到了
36% because it's all service industry. So it was just completely devastated. And I ended up spending time there and getting to know kind of some of the people who make Vegas work. and I'm hoping to tell their stories as a way of understanding the human toll that the last few years have taken. Well, Maria Konnikova, this has been just a pleasure. Thank you so much for joining me on Speaking of Psychology. I really have enjoyed talking with you. Thank you so much. It's been a pleasure, Kim.
36%，因为那里全是服务业。所以它完全被摧毁了。我最终在那里花了一些时间，去了解那些让拉斯维加斯运转的人们。我希望讲述他们的故事，以此来理解过去几年对人类造成的损失。好吧，玛丽亚·康尼科娃，这真是一次愉快的交谈。非常感谢你参加《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）。我真的很享受与你的交谈。非常感谢。这是一种荣幸，金。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you listen on Apple and you like what you hear, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyne. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你在 Apple 上收听并且喜欢你所听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Kondyne。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。